a través de sus pantallas más de 40
líderes se reunieron en la cumbre sobre
el clima una iniciativa del presidente
de eeuu joe biden que busca recuperar el
liderazgo de su país en la lucha contra
el calentamiento global
gasteiz eeuu emprende camino para
reducir nuestros gases de efecto
invernadero a la mitad a la mitad para
el final de esta década hasta allí nos
dirigimos como nación roger acciones
está meta es el doble del compromiso que
había adquirido eeuu en el acuerdo de
parís un compromiso similar al de la
unión europea que quiere recortar a más
de la mitad sus emisiones para 2030
ambas regiones y países como japón y
corea del sur también se comprometieron
a alcanzar la neutralidad de las
emisiones de carbono para 2050 es decir
emitir tanto co2 como puedan absorber
sólo hay un objetivo para las próximas
semanas y meses avanzar más rápido
tenemos que movernos más rápido para
implementar los compromisos para 2030
la cumbre fue un inusual espacio de
colaboración entre eeuu y países como
rusia o china tradicionales adversarios
china el país actualmente más
contaminante del mundo buscará la
neutralidad de las emisiones para 2060
ante este nuevo panorama mundial
el presidente de brasil yair bolsonaro
tuvo que rebajar su tradicional tono
belicoso y también se comprometió a
alcanzar las emisiones netas cero en
2050 ya terminar con la deforestación
ilegal en 2030 destacó un compromiso de
eliminar odio quiero destacar el
compromiso de eliminar la deforestación
ilegal en 2030 a través de nuestro
código forestal eso reduciría nuestras
emisiones en un 50 por ciento para esa
fecha el 50 por ciento no hace de 1100
ate a sadat
unos compromisos que todavía tienen que
pasar del papel a la realidad